[Musique]
je m'appelle thomas basso j'ai 19 ans je
suis alternant webmaster chez 78 et je
suis à l'école de hand se régler en
cours
[Musique]
ce que je fais au quotidien que les 78
c'est de la maintenance au niveau du
site internet
je vérifie que tout tous les articles et
toutes les informations qu'on lui rende
correspondent à l'actualité du jour je
m'occupe également de l'application
mobile donc sur android ios et également
sur amazon le sens que je donne à mon
métier c'est tout simplement qu'ils
aient tous les jours enfin tous les
jours il ya du nouveau
on se lève le matin on se dit qu'est ce
qu'il y aura de nouveau sur le site
internet ou question à nouveau à faire
aujourd'hui on a l'impression d'avoir
fait le tour et finalement non justement
c'est ça qui est palpitant
[Musique]
je suis en bts des six au slam donc
solutions logicielles applications et
métiers c'est tout simplement une
filière informatique de programmation et
j'apprends simplement à développer des
solutions logicielles pour les
entreprises
[Musique]
marche pas
j'ai choisi cette école les sept
formations tout simplement parce que
quand j'étais au lycée je pratique
beaucoup de la programmation sur mon
ordinateur personnel
tout simplement pour créer des eaux au
départ des personnages en 3d en 2d
j'avais même créer mon propre jeu vidéo
en c# et sharp hors yeux dorés de faire
ça juste pour moi pourquoi pas essayer
de le faire pour une entreprise
également
[Musique]